for the first time since this wretched
virus took hold
we can see a root out of the pandemic
the breakthroughs in treatment in
testing vaccines
mean that the scientific cavalry is now
in psych
and we know in our hearts the next year
we will succeed
by the spring these advances should
reduce the need for the
restrictions we've endured in 2020 and
make the whole concept of a copied
lockdown
redundant when that moment comes it will
have been made possible
by the sacrifices of millions of people
across the uk
i'm acutely conscious that no other
peacetime prime minister
has asked so much of the british people
and just as our country has risen to
every previous trial
so it has responded this time and i am
deeply grateful but the hard truth mr
speaker is that we're not there
yet first we must get through winter
without the virus spreading out of
control and squandering
our hard-won gains at exactly the time
when the burden on the nhs is always
greatest
our winter plan is designed to carry us
safely
to spring in recent weeks families and
businesses in england have
once again steadfastly observed
nationwide restrictions
and they've managed to slow the growth
of new cases
and ease the worst pressures on our nhs
i can
therefore confirm the national
restrictions
in england will end on the 2nd of
december
and they will not be renewed from next
wednesday
people will be able to leave their home
for any purpose and meet others
in outdoor public spaces subject to the
rule of six
collective worship weddings and outdoor
sports can resume
and shops personal care gyms and the
wider leisure sector
can reopen but without sensible
precautions
we would risk the virus escalating into
a winter
or new year surge the incidence of the
disease is alas
still widespread in many areas so
we're not going to replace national
measures with a free-for-all
the status quo anti-covid uh we're gonna
go back instead to a regional
tiered approach applying the toughest
measures where covid is most prevalent
and while the previous local tiers did
cut the number
and cut the r number they were not quite
enough
to reduce it below one so the
scientific advice i'm afraid
is that as we come out our tears need to
be made
tougher in particular in tier one
people should work from home wherever
possible in tier two
alcohol may only be served in
hospitality settings
as part of a substantial meal in tier
three
indoor entertainment hotels and other
accommodation
will have to close along with all forms
of hospitality
except for delivery and takeaways and
i'm very sorry obviously for the
unavoidable hardship that this will
cause for
business owners who've already endured
so much disruption
this year mr speaker
unlike the previous arrangements tears
will now be
a uniform set of rules
we've also and that's to say we won't
have negotiations on
additional measures with each uh region
it's a uniform set of rules and
uh we've learned uh from experience uh
that there are some things we can do
differently so
from the 10 pm closing time hospitality
we're going to change that so that it is
last orders at 10
with closing at 11.
in tiers one and two spectator sports
and business events will be free to
resume
inside and outside with capacity limits
and social distancing providing more
consistency with indoor performances
in theaters and concert halls
will also strengthen the enforcement
ability of local authorities including
a trained officers and new powers to
close down premises that pose a risk
to public health last later this week i
should say
we will announce which areas will fall
into which tier i hope on thursday
based on analysis of cases in
all age groups especially the
over 60s also looking at the rate by
which
cases are rising or falling the
percentage of those tested
in a local population who have coveted
and the current and projected pressures
on the nhs
i'm sorry to say we expect that more
regions will
fall at least temporally into higher
levels than before but by using
these tougher tiers and by using rapid
turnaround tests
on an ever greater scale to drive
r below one and keep it there it should
be possible
for areas to move down the tiering scale
to lower levels of restrictions
by maintaining the pressure on the virus
we can also
enable people to see more of their
family and friends
over christmas mr speaker
i can't say that christmas will be
normal
this year but in a period of adversity
time spent with loved ones
is even more precious for people of all
faiths
and none we all want some kind of
christmas we need it we certainly feel
we deserve it but what we don't want
is to throw caution to the winds and
allow the virus
to flare up again forcing us all back
into
lockdown in january so
to allow families to come together while
minimizing the risk we're working with
the devolved administrations on a
special time limited
christmas dispensation embracing the
whole of the united kingdom
and reflecting the ties of kinship
across
our islands but
this virus obviously is not going to
grant a christmas
truce it doesn't know it's christmas
uh mr speaker and families will need to
make a careful judgment about the risk
of visiting
elderly relatives we'll be publishing
guidance for those who are clinically
extremely vulnerable
on how to manage the risks in each tier
as well
as over christmas as we work to suppress
the virus
with these local tears two
scientific breakthroughs will ultimately
make these restrictions obsolete as soon
as a vaccine is approved we will
dispense it
as quickly as possible
but given that this can't be done
immediately
we will simulate simultaneously use
rapid turnaround testing the lateral
flow testing
that gives results within 30 minutes
to identify those without symptoms so
they can isolate
and avoid transmission we're beginning
to deploy
these tests in our nhs and in care homes
in england
so people will once again be able to hug
and hold hands with loved ones instead
of waving at them
through a window by the end of the year
this will allow every care home resident
to have two visitors
who can be tested twice a week
care workers looking after people in
their own homes will be offered
weekly tests from today
and from next month weekly tests will
also be available
to staff in prisons food manufacturing
and those delivering and administering
coded vaccines
we're also using testing as the house
knows
to help schools and universities stay
open
and testing will enable students to know
they can go home
safely for christmas and indeed back
from home
to university but there is another way
of using these rapid tests that is to
follow the example
of liverpool where in the last two and a
half weeks over two hundred thousand
people
have taken part in a community test
community testing
contributing to a very substantial
fall in infections
so together with nhs test and trace and
our fantastic
armed forces we will now launch a major
community
testing program offering all local
authorities in tier three areas in
england
a six-week surge of testing
the system is untried and there are
of course many unknowns but if it works
we should be able to offer those
who test negative the prospect of fewer
restrictions
for example meeting up in certain places
with others
who have also tested negative
and those towns and regions which engage
in community testing
will have a much greater chance of
easing the rules
the tiering that they currently endure
mr speaker we will also use daily
testing to ease another
restriction that has impinged on many
lives we will seek to end
automatic isolation for close contacts
of those
found positive beginning in liverpool
later this week
contacts who are tested every day for a
week
will only need to isolate if they
themselves
test positive if successful this
approach will be extended across the
health system
uh the health system next month and to
the whole of england
from january and of course we're working
with the devolved administrations to
ensure
that wales scotland northern ireland
also benefit as they should and will
from these advances
in rapid testing
but clearly the most hopeful advance of
all
is how vaccines are now edging ever
closer
to liberating us from the virus
demonstrating emphatically that this is
not a pandemic without end
we can take great heart from today's
news
which has the makings of a wonderful
british
scientific achievement the vaccine
developed with
astonishing speed by oxford university
in astrazeneca is now one of three
capable of delivering a period
of immunity we don't yet know
when any will be ready and licensed
but we have ordered 100 million doses
of the oxford vaccine and over 350
million
in total more than enough for everyone
in the uk the crown dependencies
and the overseas territories and
the nhs is preparing a nationwide
immunization program
ready next month the like of which we've
never witnessed
mr speaker 2020 has been
in many ways a tragic year when so many
have lost loved ones and faced
financial ruin and this will be still a
hard winter christmas cannot be
normal and there's a long road to spring
but we have turned a corner and the
escape route is
in sight we must hold out against the
virus
until testing and vaccines come to our
rescue and reduce
the need for restrictions and everyone
can help speed up the arrival
of that moment by continuing to follow
the rules
getting tested and self-isolating when
instructed remembering
hand space base and pulling together for
one final push
to the spring when we have every reason
to hope and believe that the
achievements of our scientists will
finally
lift the shadow of this virus and mr
speaker
i commend this statement to the house
you